we want to shoot a Minecraft WWE video
[Music]
you guys work on anything interesting a
Minecraft John Cena
videos that's one of the very first
games I ever play yeah yeah wife
threatened to divorce me if I kept
playing I'm over time I get an addictive
personality want yeah I'd rather have
crystal meth personally yeah but I did
minecraft where I not only filled out
the island I built out everything on the
island the only thing I had guy figured
out ways to kill those those things that
came at night when it got dark
man I had torches everywhere I mean I
was like this my hands were shaking from
so much caffeine
what else can I build there's a stage
called blocking where you forgot
everybody's position since this is a
fight scene blocking is extra important
you're not just standing there talking
to somebody you're moving all over the
place we went through and figured all
that blocking out figured out our stunts
too figured out our angles and generally
our coverage the mobility of the
cardboard costumes is the only X Factor
at the moment fully challenged on the
shooters the costumes are probably fall
apart is issue but that's okay go fix
them we got lots of tape
all right we're going to set up the
drone shot the first shot the champ is
here I'm gonna beat us absolve you today
as we want to do so today we begin work
on the effects for Minecraft basically I
am going through and I'm trying to find
the old minecraft video project folders
I think Simon eCos first big video was
their last minecart video way back in
the day and then after that they did a
diamonds are forever video now what
makes that video interesting is that
they remodeled those Minecraft zombies
to actually look like they have
cardboard texturing on them they have
proper reflections and texture on it to
actually look like the zombies that we
filmed with on set so that is why I'm
digging through the old build the old
guard guild library dead bodies of
videos past
[Music]
I have to press button I think right
let's see
tubby one is this it we're going to find
it look like assets from that old Freddy
W video when they went to the go-cart
like zombie crafts
why is why are these missing is the head
missing
see if this worked oh my god are you
kidding me it worked perfectly
[Music]
the other game that you really got to
check out it was really great called
rollercoaster tycoon
oh my god so much fun I like make two
million dollars two thousand five
hundred people in my Park I had so many
people in my park they were dying they
were actually walking on the street and
having heart attacks and throwing up all
over the place oh man I had
rollercoasters flying off the roller
coaster with like that's funny if we're
to look at the original footage here
basically just John Cena standing up
against the wall the entire time then
we're running out but here's the
conundrum we made a render of a
Minecraft wall being exploded outwards
and you have like the interior of the
hallway and all the cubes in the
foreground the issue is that John Cena
is in the midst of that if it was just
in front that'd be easy if it was behind
that'd be even easier but no he's in the
middle so what that means is that we
have to split the render into the
objects that are in the foreground
versus the objects that are in the
background so that we can have a roto
layer be in between but here's the other
issue that still means we have to
rotoscope and rotoscoping takes a lot of
time this has been a surprisingly fun
project to work on just because of how
easy it is to make these guys look super
realistic at first glance you can't tell
what's real and what's fake octane is so
simply basically set up your shaders and
then as far as lighting put a Sun in the
sky kind of put it roughly where the Sun
is and then it looks real I'm just
really happy that things are going
smoothly it's not usually the case
that's great that was great because we
embraced the fact that the shot isn't
necessarily the best action shot but
it's a good comedy shot now if we have
the UV horn sound effect each time I hit
one of the guys even into two Scheffer
where it's like we're building about to
get back into the Sun but just like a I
haven't color graded in almost two years
was just doing scene cut detection as he
pulls the video file into DaVinci for
Minecraft it detected so many cuts that
weren't actual cuts so scene cut
detection measures the difference
between two frames and when the
difference is high enough it marks it as
a cut and we shall allow this at 22
frames a second which means we play that
back at 24 things move a little bit
faster so the difference between frames
is actually more exaggerated so we're
getting a lot of false positives but
wrench is getting a lot of good
practicing yeah click on data levels
that's get your color space to be
accurately represented yeah video levels
broadcast video levels comes from the
day I guess that still happens where
data levels are turned into signal
levels or voltage levels so it becomes
an actual analog signal
No
no way he's going to go full-on
shonduras I think Shawn is the one that
encouraged him in the first place
all right yep sort of touched on
you